[Música]
este 30 de noviembre en el 2022 se vio
la luz el chat de gpt un programa de
Inteligencia artificial y que promete
generar contenidos coherentes incluso
textos humanizados que podrían
intervenir o algunos creen que incluso
reemplazar los procesos educativos y
creativos para entender este tema me
acompaña en directo a América Alejandro
debutmaker experto en Inteligencia
artificial para el lenguaje natural
bienvenido y gracias por estar en France
Muchas gracias Buenos días Ángela Cómo
estás lo primero que tengo que pedirle
Aunque mucha gente ya está enterada del
chat gpt es que entremos en contexto en
qué consiste esta tecnología Cómo
funciona ese algoritmo que almacena
millones y millones de datos Perfecto
es un programa de opening que permite
crear lenguaje es un chat al que
cualquier persona que ingrese a chat gpt
punto Open puede Iniciar una
conversación y preguntarle lo que quiera
lo que tiene chat gpt es que
particularmente inteligente para
responder creando contenido es decir
chat gpt no consulta bases de datos no
responde información que está guardada
sino que es capaz de crear lenguaje y
por eso este se considera que es
Inteligencia artificial desde su
aparición que es muy reciente ya hay
fuertes opiniones que se han creado
indicando que esta ya podría ser
amenazante es razonable pensar esto es
razonable pensar que por ejemplo esta
tecnología podría en momento dado hasta
reemplazar actividades humanas y me
pongo yo como ejemplo como el periodismo
sí no no Debería ser amenazante desde el
punto de vista de tenerle miedo sí es
una demostración de lo que el Deep
learning o las redes neuronales son
capaces de conseguir estas redes lo que
permiten es que las computadoras o los
sistemas digamos computacionales tengan
aprendizaje y decir entiendan Cómo
funciona el mundo cómo funcionamos los
seres humanos y sean capaces de crear y
responder de forma acorde en el corto
plazo definitivamente no es una amenaza
para tener en cuenta lo que sí es
importante entender es que cada vez más
nos hacemos más productivos Sí entonces
es posible pensar que de acá en unos
años este trabajemos menos horas o
tengamos asistentes que nos ayudan en
nuestras tareas como periodistas también
como creadores de contenido como
creadores de contenido de marketing como
redactores porque esto puede crear
lenguaje y puede responder y hacer
tareas que normalmente hacemos los seres
humanos claro es que en la misma medida
que ha generado opiniones negativas
también genera mucha mucho entusiasmo
por todas las posibilidades que ofrece
Cuáles son algunas de ellas por ejemplo
yo le puedo pedir a chat gpt que escriba
una carta para realizar un reclamo No si
quiero hacer un reclamo legal puede
reemplazar lo que hace un abogado en
redactar una carta documento este puede
redactar un contrato puede escribir un
folleto de marketing puede redactar una
nota un cuento es decir tiene capacidad
para crear lenguaje de la misma forma
sabe responder lo que hay que tener en
cuenta cuando lo utilicen es que todavía
no utilice información actual utiliza
información con la que fue entrenada
está creando el lenguaje entonces sobre
la precisión chat gpt aún no es preciso
en responder lo que sí es responde bien
desde el punto de vista del lenguaje
bueno y otra pregunta que nos surge es
si la Inteligencia artificial aprende
basada en el conocimiento al que sus
programadores le permiten acceder
confiar en la guía implica también
confiar en sus programadores o en sus
creadores
a ver chat gpt definitivamente
tiene está orientado por Cómo fue creado
decir quienes lo crearon los algoritmos
que utilizan de alguna forma definen
mucho el tono que habla de Qué temas
puede hablar y tiene límites a lo que
puede realizar chat gpt está entrenado
con información que fue creada por los
humanos chat gpt fue entrenada con 175
mil millones de documentos que permiten
que haya podido entender Cómo funciona
el lenguaje y la Inteligencia artificial
lo que hace es permite derivar Cuáles
son las funciones Cuál es la lógica con
la que se crea lenguaje en este caso
entonces
aprendió de los seres humanos porque los
documentos que utiliza son documentos
que fueron creados por seres humanos y
por eso también sus respuestas nos
resultan tan naturales chat gpt no
entienden si los conceptos que están por
detrás todavía no tiene conciencia lo
que se llama un sistema de Inteligencia
artificial ahora lo que nosotros no
sabemos Aún es si después de tanto
entrenamiento de alguna forma como los
seres humanos Cuando somos bebés o niños
muy pequeños no llegamos a crear esa
conciencia nosotros mismos como
resultado del aprendizaje profundo está
por verse qué va a pasar y
Definitivamente sí los programadores
quienes lo crearon han definido ciertas
políticas con las que funcione con este
trabajo con esto que usted me dice uno
entiende que interactuar con esta
Inteligencia artificial puede llegar a
generar la impresión de que nos estamos
comunicando con otro ser humano Cómo
podemos gestionar esa percepción De qué
manera debe manejarse
bueno Es realmente difícil no chat gpt
ha pasado en varias instancias lo que se
llama el test de turing es cuando una
persona no puede definir si quien está
respondiendo es un ser humano o es una
máquina hay programas y chat gpt mismo
tiene un programa en su Api en su en su
conector que permite identificar si ese
texto o ese ese contenido fue creado por
un robot no hay una forma única si
podemos confundirnos si una respuesta a
un texto fue creado por chat gpp la
mejor forma es construir un programa que
permite justamente hacer esa contra
validación pero así ha sentido común y
no podemos todavía darnos cuenta usted
lo que nos está planteando es que
estamos teniendo conversaciones qué
limitaciones éticas hay en este
desarrollo de la Inteligencia artificial
bueno Ahí es donde entra la ética de
quienes lo crearon y quienes lo
programaron de qué le permiten hablar y
qué este qué es lo que puede responder
Ese es el primer la primer definición
ética es porque nos lo han creado y la
segunda definición ética es de Qué
documentos ha producido el aprendizaje
No de alguna forma chat gpt incorpora
los mismos prejuicios los mismos valores
de todos los documentos que ha sido que
han sido utilizados para para entrenarlo
por eso es que hay que tener mucho
cuidado porque la Inteligencia
artificial lo que hace es incorpora los
prejuicios y los valores éticos de
quienes producimos ese documento Y de
alguna forma va incorporando los mismos
las mismas desviaciones que tenemos las
personas en nuestro en la forma que
conceptualizamos la realidad y el
lenguaje en estas primeras fases el chat
gpt está disponible para quien lo quiera
utilizar de manera gratuita sin embargo
lo que se espera es que más adelante sea
monetizado y aquí le quiero preguntar
Pues cuál es ese Universo de
posibilidades Y si esto iría un paso Más
allá de las redes sociales que ahora
están en crisis después del Gran Boom
que tuvieron inicialmente
a ver sí es gratuito cualquier persona
puede Ingresar a lo Busca en Google
directamente chat gpt y le va a dar el
link tiene que crearse un usuario y lo
puede probar y utilizar y le recomiendo
a todos laudia a todos en la audiencia
que lo hagan porque es una experiencia
deslumbrante las primeras veces que uno
lo utiliza
chat gpt es caro para la compañía que lo
creó porque utiliza mucho capacidad de
cómputo Entonces ya están apareciendo
opciones pagas que permiten responder
más rápido y responder de temas más
amplios sí podemos esperar que sean
servicios pagos en el futuro por lo
menos por el momento por el costo que
tienen ahora si miramos a unos años
adelante tres cuatro cinco años adelante
el costo de la Inteligencia artificial
va a ser casi cero va a bajar Y eso va
por eso va a ser que seamos justamente
los seres humanos hiper productivos
porque el costo del conocimiento va a
ser Va a ser muy muy bajo bien y
finalmente muy rápidamente pues toda
esta información que aprende el chat gpt
tiene que venir de algún lado no y
cuando la información tiene un origen
específico pues esto implica unos
derechos Entonces si él le puede sugerir
a usted cocinar escribir o hacer
cualquier actividad pues qué pasa con
esos derechos de creación que venían
antes de él es una excelente pregunta es
uno de los temas que se está
considerando mismo qué pasa con el texto
que crea chat gpt si no tiene derechos
de autor quienes crearon el chat gpt
mismo también parte del conocimiento y
el aprendizaje sobre las reglas de cómo
funciona el lenguaje requiere incorporar
lo que significa la propiedad
intelectual este y la expectativa es que
lo incorpore si uno va a copiar o a
publicar texto que fue copiado por chat
gpt chat gpt lo va a saber y lo va a
poder identificar este es increíble
porque es tan grande el volumen de
documentos que ha sido utilizado para
entrenarlo este donde estas reglas
propias del lenguaje de las reglas de
del uso del contenido también han sido
incorporadas se van a ver que que no
permite realizar plagio este y si uno le
pide plagiar es probablemente va a
responder de alguna forma que no no está
en su en su capacidad de hacerlo